dude tell me the best party story i mean  you said you were putting rock stars to  shame i mean there's more than i could  ever possibly tell who have you put  ashamed there's quite a few nba players  over the years that we've gone toe to  toe it's only fun when you tell this i  know i'll give you one when i failed  okay we were out for juwan howard's  birthday party in new york city and it  was me fan jerk nash yeah wits i think  and some other folks steve nash ended up  meeting his then wife that's all crazy  and i was but we go in there we and then  me in particular started buying think it  was wild turkey by the bottle and  drinking it out of the bottle it was  ugly let's just say that it wasn't long  after that my head was hanging out the  window of the limo getting sick and all  these guys are laughing at me and thank  god that was pre iphone otherwise i  could never live it down i still can't  let it down with these guys